[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben in diesem video geht so
ein bisschen um eine anstehende ramadan
reihe und zwar wie ihr wisst wollte ich
das genauso wie im letzten jahr machen
denn ich habe letztes jahr schon direkt
gestartet mit der ramadan reihe in dem
ich alle zwei tage ein neues rezept
video hochladen
wie auch im letzten jahr gibt es in
diesem jahr wieder rezepte aus aller
welt insbesondere aus den ländern syrien
libanon palästina wegen haben sie und
marokko natürlich marokko ohne ende und
ich bin total froh dass ich euch die
rezepte zeigen kann und ihre auch immer
ganz froh drum denn auf deutsch gibt es
nicht ganz so viele rezepte auf youtube
die rezepte die denke ich mir nicht
selber aus denn wie ihr wisst bin ich
aus der türkei der haben sie aus
palästina die frage kommt auch immer
ganz offen und ich habe dadurch den
großen vorteil dass ich dann in seiner
familie also fragen kann oder in der
gemeinde ich habe total viele freunde
auf diesen ländern und die gehen immer
fleißig die rezepte ich teste wir dann
zu hause aus und dann für mich sie für
euch heute geht so ein bisschen um die
dattel denn datteln sind gerade an
ramadan total wichtig die dattel bricht
im traditionellen sinne das fasten ich
zeige euch jetzt dass ihr datteln auch
befüllen könnt und drei varianten wie
ihr sie befüllen könnt und währenddessen
quatschen wir auch noch ein bisschen
gerade zum befüllen nämlich immer ganz
gerne diese großen doppel müsst ihr
einfach mal im supermarkt schauen die
hier sind aus dem libanon und diesen
total schön groß ich mache die packung
gerade einmal auf und dann entfernen wir
zuallererst die kerne
darin haben unter allen obstsorten den
höchsten energiegehalt und die haben so
viele gute nährstoffe unter anderem
magnesium zink eisen ihr tut euch damit
nur gutes also auch außerhalb von norma
dann könnt ihr gerne jeden tag bis zu
drei daten in essen ich habe sogar mal
gelesen in einer studie studie
schuljungen haben sie herausgefunden
dass eine frau vor der schwangerschaft
vier wochen vorher täglich drei daten
der gestern ist hat ihr tatsächlich die
geburt erleichtert das haben sie an
mehreren frauen ist der wahnsinn ist es
wirklich so so genau jetzt habe ich mir
hier im parterre zurechtgelegt und wird
jetzt erstmal den stein herausnehmen den
kern nicht den stein
sobald dann dem kern entfernt habt geht
es weiter mit der füllung ich habe hier
drei für euch vorbereitet die erste ist
wohl die einfachste und die gibt's sogar
so zu kaufen ich muss aber gerne selber
und zwar sind dass hier die walnüsse
genau um die wahlen ist und dann nehmt
ihr euch jetzt einfach aus und gibt das
ein mal hier rein hier ist er jetzt auch
platz dadurch dass wir den kern heraus
genommen haben so und das ist quasi so
schon unsere erste doppel füllung euch
ist wahrscheinlich aufgefallen dass ich
immer ramadan sage das kommt einer vom
arabischen viele haben sich im letzten
jahr geschrieben warum sagst den ramadan
das heißt doch ramazan ja das ist dann
auf türkisch heißt es ramazan aber genau
ist nimmt dann gerne so die
übergreifende ja wie sagt man also ich
da kommt man gerne ramadan will dass es
einfach arabischen arabisch ist ja
übergreifend für alle muslimische länder
eingehen
apropos häufig gestellte fragen unter
meine ramadan videos die wohl häufigste
frage ja sagt ruhig haben sie ja es ist
genau was hast du die wohl häufigste
frage ist tatsächlich fastest du oder
fasste tier dazu muss ich euch sagen es
liegt ja auf der hand dass je natürlich
fasten denn ich bin gottseidank
kerngesund das heißt ich bin berechtigt
zu fasten
wer nicht fasten darf sind jetzt
schwangere oder kranke oder schwache
leute leute die auf medikamente
angewiesen worden oder auf reisen sind
genau und ich muss auch dazu sagen ich
glaube auch nicht dass diejenigen dann
im bekannten- oder verwandtenkreis
hingehen und sagen du warst du hast du
was ist also das macht man ja nicht an
ich brauch es gibt ja auch leute die
können nicht weil sie eine krankheit
haben und dann möchten dies war
vielleicht gar nicht preisgeben da fragt
man einfach nicht deshalb sage ich jetzt
schon unterlassen einfach diese frage
genießen wir einfach dieses ramadama
dann zusammen und ja um gelassen unsere
frage nicht stellen
x reihe war genau die augen endlich mehr
noch das fasten sondern wir fast genau
so natürlich natürlich klar denn wir
sind wie ich schon sagte gott sei dank
kerngesund wir fasten gerne es ist ja
auch noch muss ja auch dazu sagen es ist
ja nicht nur fast es ist nur nicht nur
der verzicht auf essen sondern gerade an
ramadan gehen die muslime in sich sie
legen ihre schlechten eigenschaften ab
es ist wie so ein neustart was wieder
auch heute stehen sie sagen weil sie der
grund ist warum ihr fasten ist wir haben
und sollen sich so viel wie die haben
das stimmt aber allerdings nicht
natürlich hat es verlassen das tun aber
jetzt größer sind jetzt wieder die
schlechten eigenschaften ablehnen neuer
auf aufnehmen und dann quasi nach
ramadan im zuckerfest danach ist wieso
neustart
gerade haben seine das sind jetzt meine
daten mit den walnüssen gefüllt und
moment steht es mal kurz ab und ich bin
noch ein bisschen kokosraspeln drüber
von hamza und wo hast du denn deine mama
genauso wir damit jetzt mal weitermachen
genau wir machen jetzt mit dem marzipan
weiter legt nochmal ganz risse
kokosraspeln ab ich war schon mal ganz
gut die hände fänd ich habe ja gerade
schon so von doping geschwärmt und
wusstet ihr dass datteln das
schlaganfall risiko vermindert also es
ist wirklich so
und auch die immun also so ein buch das
quasi weil auch einfach so viele
vitamine hat und nährstoffe und ich
mochte früher ehrlich gesagt keine daten
vor
ich glaube vier jahre mochte ich die gar
nicht und genau und irgendwann einfach
auch während der madame ich musste
irgendwie da drin ist ein fachverlag
hansa hat mir sagen wir haben sie hat
mir da
schoko bongrain getan damit ich das mag
und so habe ich dem lieben gelernt und
jetzt kann ich gar nicht mehr ohne auch
das ganze jahr über quasi ja niemals
genau du hattest du warten schon
gespannt drauf
das hier ist jetzt marzipanrohmasse
findet ihr in jedem supermarkt in der
buck abteilung und jetzt erleben uns
hier einfach so ein stück mit den händen
und dann geben wir das in die dattel
rein also mit den händen formt und
einfach reingehen und verschließen und
ich find's schön wenn man das noch ein
bisschen außen sieht das noch mal sagen
ich habe ja ich habe es gemerkt aber das
war so und dann sieht man es halt ich
finde es schön wenn man es halt so recht
rustikal aussieht ihr könnt natürlich
auch ganz verstecken aber ich finde so
schön bitteschön eine weitere sache die
ich gerne ansprechen möchte ist das ist
viele geschwister gibt die tatsächlich
alleine sind andermatt an das heißt
vielleicht gibt es ja welche die sind
konvertiert vielleicht geht's welche die
haben einfach keine familie hier und
diesen dann leider auch allein beim
start und es ist einfach schön wenn ihr
dann sagt wenn ich zum beispiel man
kennt von dem ihr wisst diese person ist
alleine sagt der helcom wir essen heute
mal zusammen oder her ich es meiner
familie gut ist herzlich eingeladen
denn das solltet ihr auch bedenken es
ist nicht schön wenn man sowieso schon
den ganzen tag fastet und so ein
bisschen in sich gekehrt ist und dann
auch noch abends wo jeder wirklich mit
der familie gemeinsam sind dass man dann
alleine ist also achtet da so ein
bisschen drauf dass das liegt mir
persönlich sehr am herzen denn wenn wir
das auch mal so meine familie war dann
im urlaub ich war hier und dann war das
auch so dass ich einfach gelacht
nirgendwo es jetzt viel schöner wenn man
gemeinsam essen würde das sind jetzt die
deppen mit der marzipan verlogen schaut
mal ich finde es super abwechslung und
die dritte variante ist es meine
persönliche lieblings variante mit
mascarpone und pistazien und hierfür
nehmen uns auch da die entspannte dazu
nehmen uns ein bisschen stolz sorry und
dann genau nehmen uns ein bisschen was
kaputt ich habe das war schon zu viel
und dann einfach rein geben genau
einfach rein geben
ganz kuba streichen dann also man sollte
es schon sehen und dann geb dir da ganz
einfach pistazien drüber liegt man will
ich habe zum beispiel in meinem
freundeskreis auch unter anderem viele
nicht-muslime und mir ist immer so ein
anliegen die dann auch zum start also
zum fastenbrechen einzuladen
und genau so könnt ihr das ja auch
machen denn schließlich werde er auch
mal zum weihnachts ist eingeladen
wenn man allein schon mit der arbeit
geht man zum weihnachts ist und deswegen
ist ja immer schön wenn ihr dann ein
leidet und dass die dann auch sehen wie
das so
während des ramadan abläuft genau genau
außerdem ist es ja auch so ein weit
verbreitetes vorurteil dass wir dann den
ganzen tag über fast nichts essen nichts
trinken so richtig vollhauen
vielleicht könnte er dann zeigen es ist
gar nicht so denn es ist ja wirklich so
dass man ein bisschen vom wagen auch
freilassen sollte dass man sich nicht
bis hier oben in voll stoff mit
irgendwelchen ungesunden zeugt vor allem
tut mir den gefallen und euch selber
auch trinkt nur wasser die meisten
wissen dass ich kenne es selber man hat
einfach mal lust auf so richtig schön
schluck liebe oder irgendwas anderes
macht einfach nicht tut euch damit
keinen gefallen
ich muss zugeben das schlimmste also das
was ich am meisten vermisse genau ich
wollte sagen ist kaffee kaffee entzieht
dem körper wasser und deswegen ist es
auch nicht ratsam kaffee zu trinken also
trinkt einfach nur wasser und dann seid
also seid ihr der richter keine humus
macht den fehler lich ich komme jetzt
die langsam zum abschluss ist schon so
ein richtiges lava video geworden da
haben wir jedenfalls möchte ich mich
noch bei ja er habe daraufhin die reden
wobei du darfst reden das manchmal reden
jedenfalls möchte ich mich noch bei zwei
personen bedanken die erste person ist
moore phoenix der uns erlaubt hat und
genehmigt hat sein lied zwar mama
barbara dieses lied was gerade total
dorum ist dass wir das benutzen dürften
für unser in tropea solchen aufgefallen
und wie findet ihr übrigens unser intro
jedenfalls schreibe ich euch sein
youtube kann er auch mal hier unten in
die infobox wenn ihr nicht schon kennen
schon alle aber schaut gerne vorbei und
die zweite person ist kommen muss man
auch würdigen kommt dass bruder ist ein
paar jahren der uns im letzten jahr
schon so unterstützt haben
genau dieses mal haben wir ihn fürs auto
benutzt und letztes jahr war das ja das
intro was euch album laune versetzt hat
also vielen lieben dank an euch und ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß bei
unserer ramadan reihe
und wie gesagt alle zwei tage ein neues
video abonniert den kanal damit ihr die
videos nicht verpasst teils unbedingt
sagt euren freunden euren schwestern
tanten allen und genau wir haben uns so
viel mühe gegeben und hoffe natürlich
dass es euch gefällt und leiden und wie
gesagt 30 teile nur so unterstützte uns
um so können auch ganz viele andere
davon profitieren und wir wünschen ihnen
jetzt ramadan mubarak damit ein karim
alles liebe euch bis bald es ist ramadan
die schönste zeit
was mich doch singen
[Musik]